e hoje vai dizer que falar um pouco
booth como ferrari
vamos falar em inovação passar é que
você há pouco falar um pouco do sul mas
nem tanto o clube quanto ao futuro do
velho fazer esquecer a fazer minha força
sobre as linhas e hoje só peito uma taça
ligada àquilo que hoje está muito
próxima
muita certeza um marco cultural aqui o
que é minha pequena intervenção seria
ser capaz de deixar uma elevação acima
tudo com uma simples assim uma série de
características tão ocas muitos do que
os que estão aqui nesta sala
nós vamos falar não tem passado por
sendo algo que é injetado na economia
anual seria que ele ficasse claro
cultural que não precisam conhecer
porque o desafio do ano passado e com
exemplos nós sejamos capazes 16 fiquei
porque 40 difícil o governo olhar
frestas solução uma função pega o
playoff
há pouco quando estava em branco fez o
jogo numa altura muito engraçada noite a
pensar um pouco daquilo que foi o jogo
brasília - para a imagem que fez há
pouco havia várias questões e fazer um
aluno de 12 anos
o senhor viu algum verso falou para nós
no fundo era um objeto primeira
colocação
eu quero um homem informado que o valor
só é jô inicial é p
na prática o sinal nos tiram surf eles
escolhidos os velhos marcamos hotéis
fazem todo o mistério e uma infinidade
de tarefas no fim
e por falar em certas e destilados viaja
assim nós já percebemos hoje é continuar
pessoas durante a sessão
usaram o seu smartphone como definir as
diferenças que neo lado e eu fui até o
momento mágico mas foi quando alguém
fica para jogar pessoalmente e por
aquilo que era a sua aparência e viu
todo outro uma certa admiração e dizia
que nossa vida loucura muito fala e isso
foco por esse dia
por isso o time só sabe precisar mas não
só
nós olhamos pra que ele usa o computador
assim fato aquilo que nós temos é o
conforto do seu computador dois f também
o próprio para fazer seu lado sabe as
tropas sua visão e sugerir permitem
serem chamados
o que não se entende o nosso fim temos
que olhar pra gente se vê por lá dentro
estragou a relva costa falava no final
da aula encarou esse equipamento aqui ou
então é sinal de deus faziam já tem
cinco ex companheiro dela é uma carga de
60 quilos haviam pensado
mas essa eu não tem volta
ontem voltou a treinar como se no
veículo é tripulado representam a
revisão de uma série que só foi capaz de
ver qual é aquilo que era convencional
que são dependentes acima tudo da forma
como o software irá alterar a forma como
podemos fazer policiamento e fazer tudo
você me contou que já teria há toda uma
série de doenças
uma seria uma infinidade de munições a
um custo mais baixo e com muito maior
incerteza
aquilo que existe em termos anuais e uma
vida melhor nos a mulher em certa medida
aquilo que é o nosso e em portugal ao
contrário do que muitos possam pesar já
site do melhor que existe em termos
globais nesta matéria que esse
equipamento que vocês vêem aqui 80 que o
senhor pensa que pelé é incorporação
nacional software mons eletrônica
tudo isso é comportamento e isso é que o
que nosso tudo que você pode inventar
muito no futebol não tem isso sim é tão
bom
de sexy a presença de um super all é né
não
uma das coisas que eu tinha consciência
que nunca devemos acreditar em superar
mais uma superbalada tecnologia todas as
tecnologias na rua isaac hoje de tudo
têm vantagens e muito nossa vida
apresentam também aos próprios riscos e
ameaças à privacidade também como os
próprios que são um desafio muito grande
para a nossa sociedade mas nunca esquece
não é
aqui o nosso lugar por mais não quer
dizer que se o carro junto do que viu o
que falar na apas foi um país que vem e
tira uma forma que nós tiramos os
sucessos precisa o que não é o que ele
precisa é difícil viver mais uns
é preciso tirar é voltado fazer entregas
luz nos encaminhava para destruir assim
o brasil
o paulo é difícil não precisou quando
nós pensávamos se a sola na fé
ele sabe se dirigiram somente surgiu a
versão on line
foi preciso chamar 300 latas subsidiar
seu lado cria uma bolada e fui capaz de
criar uma das épocas mais aulas em
portugal diz pensar votar aquilo que é
essencial em sua voz com vontade aqui
nessa tecnologia 100% portuguesa é o
fruto do sonho de um conjunto de pessoas
que é a cettrans seguiu que visa
combater e fazer aquilo estava você faz
com a certeza de chegar com custo zero
jô é bobô é impossível determinar os 20
jornais como quem diz levitas combateu o
mesmo equipamento fosse estou aqui há um
caso e no caso de ocorrência com
equipamento tão mal e maricá foi
considerado numa altura em que estamos a
dar a volta a uma altura entre portugal
precisa de maiores junto tem que ser
nossa
o sítio que eu considero muito estudo
geral ao cliente em uma réplica uma tela
realista choram por seus homens morreram
no naufrágio com ele em 1947 o maior
naufrágio
até hoje as 152 pessoas que iriam tomar
suas flores futebol além de atuar como
tirar não deixou lá o sacrifício voltar
a fazer mais um gol e lançado em 2010
ocorra aqui que é o nosso passado e
nossa história 35 da nota
a pequena mensagem final podendo o
público alvo costa gosta de fazer uma
ficção
os músicos pelo melhor lixão que vamos
fazer aquilo que não foi fácil
eu sei que eu disse como conseguiu ser a
mais provas agora estamos hoje a janela
era assim acho que posso fazer é que
algumas infecções
a primeira perícia os convidados fizeram
daquilo pela fifa